sono tutti ragazzi per lui di questo
nuovissimo video con il buon fabio era
un sacco di tempo che non facevo una
dirmi e chiacchierate con voi su roche
click perché ovviamente giocata rocket
league sono competitive eccetera ma
facciamo una bella chiacchierata come ai
vecchi tempi quindi non pensando alla
partita ma giocando tra di noi
non so se te notato siamo nella stanza
nuova e non è la mia stanza nuova della
green room ma è la stanza temporanea
dove sono collocato finché non mi si
sbloccherà la stanza nuova
sull'operativo di videogiochi quando
arrivi il livello a livello 100 t si
sblocca stan
quindi chiedo venia se effetti strisce
di doverne accusa parliamo parlo come
mangio se effettivamente c'è un po di
eco nella stanza perché questa è già
tanto che ci a internet figuriamoci i
pannelli fonoassorbenti e se comunque il
video è un po qualitativamente non come
al solito per questo motivo se vuoi
vedere dove è appoggiata la videocamera
di mettere st ridere ma quello lo
rivelerò tra in un'altra chiacchierata
di rockets league andando ad ragazzi b
dico che sono riuscito appunto trovare
un posto che abbia internet parecchio
lontano da casa mia però vedo comunque
che non funziona benissimo perché se
guardiamo le partite i giocatori online
mi da zero però cippa lippa può
aggiungermi agli amici spera riso
avrebbe fotografare in breve termine se
no effettivamente e dovrò giocare solo
giochi single player perché questo wifi
non gli permette di giocare a giochi
online spero per un paio di settimane
quindi non pertanto però spero si
risolva prima delle due settimane
comunque chi se ne frega tanto oggi vi
racconto una delle mie storielle quindi
posso giocare anche chill su una mappa
che è così e ho perso spero che vi sia
piaciuto oh ragazzi oggi vi racconto di
quella volta che che mi rubarono la
macchina però anche se gesù
vedo che il wifi non è l'unico nemico
oggi quella volta che mi rubarono la
macchina questa cosa non è finita nei
kit pate qualcosa però non è la mia
macchina che hanno rubato adesso perché
adesso cielo la macchina fare un video
anche su quello tra poco visto che ha
fatto uno della patente
ma questo è il racconto di come io sono
entrato in possesso della mia macchina
perché una volta presa la patente quindi
le tappe famiglie ormai hai preso la
patente quindi questa vale edizione si è
rotta definitivamente finita è finita
ce l'hai fatta no oggi ragazzi per colpa
del fatto che non finì la maledizione
qual è la volta in cui io preti la
patente ma la narrazione continuò anche
dopo perché allora vi spiego poi una
volta presa la patente io ho detto beh è
finita ce l'ho fatta basta prendiamo la
macchina quelli di quel che hanno la
patente che hanno fatto la patente lo
sapranno i neopatentati non possono
guidare tutte le macchine che quindi non
è che posso prendermi il ferro rozzo
così non si può fare perché i
neopatentati per un anno da quando hanno
preso la patente non possono guidare
automobili che superano un certo
rapporto peso potenza che è questo che
questa è la spiegazione stretta di
quello che quindi io posso guidare solo
macchine del match
non è vero sto scherzando non solo
macchine darsi anzi posso guidare anche
macchine carine ma non tutte le macchine
quindi prendo ho preso la patente ho
detto finalmente voglio godermi la mia
maledettissima patente e quindi voglio
comprare la macchina dei miei sogni o
che dei miei sogni e non la posso
comprare perché sono patentato allora
cosa faccio compro la macchina che più
si avvicina alle mie esigenze
facendo una cernita totale tutte le
macchine esistenti al mondo
le due sono due macchine che è di più si
avvicinavano al mio gusto sono lati
cross e
agi renegade tra le due tra le due
mi piace di più ora utilizzerò dei
termini perché chi si intende di
macchine mi guarderà e di sanguinerà
hanno le orecchie
però preferisco il culo dell'ati cross
ma la faccia della renegade tra le due
hanno scelto la renegade perché aveva
illuso vi piacerà di più
vado a milano in un posto che non che
non dico a cercare cercare di comprare
di acquistare una jeep renegade perno
patentati che tra parentesi perché
questa cosa importante specificare io la
macchina non la volevo usata la volevo a
km zero vado a comprare la macchina stop
buongiorno avere acquistare un chip
renegade versione per neopatentati il
tipo di guarda e fa ma non esiste e io
mostrando il telefono tutto fiero esiste
caro c'è scritto qua a che si hanno
fatto pochissimi persi intorno al 2016 e
l'hanno tolta dalla produzione per
neopatentati quindi l'altro visto l'ho
usato in giro a 1 non mi dice che non
esiste
2 che sfiga maledetta come l'ha detto
che stava per arrivederci sono
strettamente a cercare di comprare lati
prof
jeep retta via salve vorrei comprare una
e ti cross versione neopatentati non la
voglio usata la voglio che un 30 di tipo
riguarda di fatto effetto
ne abbiamo una in deposito te la faccio
vedere qua in foto però dobbiamo farla
arriva
guarda le foto sfoglio dalle tele dario
il computer mi ha fatto delle foto le
socie baccarini sapevo già come una
tigre carina si si fa l'arrivare che
vengo a vederle poi mi piace dalla pop
bene ok passa per cui le dicono anche
già passa mercoledì dovrà passare una
settimana perché dobbiamo farla ri
dovevo richiede la falla arrivare qua
poi tu vieni la vedi se ti piace a roma
passa una settimana torno lì ci porta in
un parcheggio
ok tanto vi sembra un parcheggio
pubblici porta vicino una macchina ci fa
questa questa è la e la macchina io la
guardo
per tali da karina però mancavano due
due cose che avevo visto nella foto che
cerchi in lega che fa la differenza cioè
che lega scambia la mattina così a così
e il portapacchi sopra che a molti piace
montino
a me personalmente la macchina per la
voglio col portapacchi e la quarta
pacchi per me lavati è bellissima senza
sembra tipo un nuovo cioè non so il mio
concetto di me lo so perché portava a
chiglia civili la guardo nostra macchina
quando giro era un po sporcano la ma chi
spera sporca di fango e dove caputi
sigep strani sia sisport cev è nuova già
non è possibile che le strade nuova come
fai sempre disporre ma ora guardo di
loro non va bene comunque lo guardi go
vasi carina ma si può mettere il
portapacchi collega perché nelle foto
dicono così che comunque è bella la
macchina col portava ti cerchi è bella
anche così è perché proprio è meglio
così come questa e le file indico una
macchina di fianco di fianco a quella lì
che era una t cross uguale con i cerchi
in lega con il portapacchi tato
pulitissima e venendo una macchina
che nuova ed è sporca di fango non è che
non ha il portapacchi ce si lega come me
l'hai fatta vedere ma quella di fianco e
ci sa di chi è ed è più pulita quei
cerchi lega col porta a parte ci
incredibile quella quella vorrei quella
non è non è comunque male mi piace
aprila che così guardo dentro lui fa
così fa questo col telecomando ragazzi
insomma perché questo si si apre l'altra
macchina
quello mi stava vendendo una mattina di
un altro incredibile ha fatto così saper
calato il mio io appena sapete tutto si
se mancini ed entrò nella macchina
quella nuova voi cerchi in lega ha
portato finalmente maledizione entrista
macchina va bene sto dentro cinque
minuti neanche tanto va beh dai andiamo
in ufficio che la prendiamo di cosa che
ho che credo in contento mi ha un
ufficio dove eravamo all'inizio ci
sediamo pronti perché non so neanche
come spiegarlo a sta roba perché viverla
è stato il wiping emozionante se diamo
il tipo fa
ok allora te la posso dare a questo però
con gli incentivi se fai il mutuo da
parli meno così se io paghi tutto subito
fai questo poi quell'altro l'incidere
non ho capito niente di quello che mi ha
detto adesso scontiamo mio padre facendo
parli con mio padre e poi mio papà
valori passi al telefono e gli dico papa
che te lo fa perché se non risolviamo
proprio papà sentiva all'acido che non
capire niente che ha il telefono più che
non ci si così facciamo così facciamo
dire aufiero è a posto
ah ok perfetto che mio papà compra la ok
papa allora si mette di asm essere un po
non va il sig
non va il sito non so perché noi non va
al sito dove dove ci sono i dati della
ma non va
siamo quanto siamo pronti a due ora di
tutta la macchina di un'altra strana le
chiavi che trasforma j premier esiste un
po tanto vuoi stiamo altro bar cioè
sfottò anni va vaden ai partito è
ripartito a opere vende ripartiti
senti ti devo dire una cosa e io dimmi
la macchina l'abbiamo già venduta
[Musica]